hey guys today it is the 27th of August
my name is Jess and you're watching
games but nice new fallout 4 concept art
has dropped to give you a closer look at
the upcoming RPG but those two showed
off four pieces on their Twitter account
which will be included in the art of
fallout 4 art book that the studio is
working on with Dark Horse Comics the
dev also said that the artists have
created twice as many game assets for
Fallout 4 then were created for Skyrim
the art book is due out on December 22
and the game will land on November 10
Capcom has confirmed that the newest
character to join the street fighter 5
fighting roster will be female wrestler
rainbow maker previously rainbow maker
had only appeared in 1998 street fighter
alpha 3 capcom have said that she will
have a large variety of high-flying
moves and her v-trigger ability will
involve calling in her tag team partner
nadeshiko Capcom explained by calling
nadeshiko at the right time you'll be
able to set up sneaky attacks and
punishing command grab mix ups that are
sure to knock the stuffing out of your
opponent players who enjoy close combat
guessing games and striking fear into
the hearts of opponent will find our
maker an absolute delight to play makers
V skill is Mike performance where she
whips out her microphone to give a
monologue to the crowd during this time
she can absorb an opponent's hit and
chuck her microphone at them when she's
done if you want to strike fear into the
hearts of opponents by smashing them in
the face with audio equipment or your
ass street fighter 5 is out next to
March although it's playable beta test
for pre-orders starts tomorrow and
hopefully we'll go much better than the
last one and finally in Assassin's Creed
news Ubisoft have drops the PC release
date for syndicate and we got a look at
the first image from the Assassin's
Creed movie while the Southlands Creed
syndicate will be coming to ps4 and xbox
one on October 23 it won't be arriving
on PC until no
the pc port is being designed by the
Ubisoft Kiev team in Ukraine so long as
they aren't the same guys that worked on
the batman arkham knight pc port
everything should be right or fully in
movie news the film adaptation of
Assassin's Creed revolves around Callum
lynch a new character created
specifically for the movie the film is
set to include both new and familiar
characters and much like the games will
involve the protagonist unlocking
genetic memories that let him play out
the life of argula a 15th century
spanish assassin the first image of
Michael Fassbender decked out in his
assassins garb was released earlier
today like Desmond lish will be using
the skills he learns in the past to take
on the Knights Templar in the present
day let me know down in the comments if
you're keen to see Assassin's Creed on
the big screen you can add two games but
we've got stories on 426 going gold and
fable legends skipping steam that is
everything I want to tell you about
today do remember that tomorrow I have
my top five favorite stories of the
whole gaming week are ready to go for
you so season